I think we now have all the tools we
need to move forward so just to review a
little bit of the last video we said
we're trying to model out the
probability distribution of how many
cars might pass in an hour and the first
thing we did is we we sat at that
intersection and we found a pretty good
expected value of our random variable in
this random variable just to go back to
the top we define the random variable is
a number of cars that pass in an hour at
a certain point on a certain road and we
said that you know we measure it a bunch
we set that they're a bunch of hours and
we got a pretty good estimate of this
and we say it's lambda and we said okay
we wanted to model it as a binomial
distribution so if this is a binomial
distribution then this lambda would be
equal to the number of trials times the
probability of success per trial and so
if we could view a trial as an interval
of time this is the total number of
successes in an hour
success in hour and then so this would
be success in a smaller interval in
interval and this would be the
probability of success in that smaller
interval and in the last video we tried
it out we said oh well what if we make
this interval a minute and this is the
probability of success per minute we'd
have of maybe a reasonable description
of what we're just grabbing vote if more
than one car passes in a minute and they
said oh let's make this per second and
this is the probability of success per
second but then we still have the
problem more than one car could pass in
a second very easily so what we wanted
to do is we want to take the limit as
this approaches infinity and then see
what what kind of formula we get from
the math gods so if we describe this as
a binomial distribution with the limit
as it approaches infinity we could say
that the probability that X is equal to
some number so the probability that our
random variable is equal to I don't know
three cars in a particular hour exactly
three cars per tick in an hour is equal
to oh we want to take the limit as it
approaches infinity right the limit as n
approaches infinity of n choose K all
right we're going to have K moments in
time right because n approaches infinity
these
ervil's become super SuperDuper small
right so these become moments in time so
we have we're going to have close to an
infinite number of moments and this is
the number of successful moments where
cars pass if we have three moments where
cause car where there where there was a
success where a car passed and we had a
total of three cars passed right or
seven cars seven moments where it was
true that a car passed and we would have
total seven cars pass in the hour so
just finishing up with our bundle and
distribution end moments choose K
successes times the probability of
success what's the probability of
success we said if this is so this could
be you know if n is so this would be n
what's P equal to P is equal to lambda
divided by n right n times P is lambda
so let me just write that down P is
equal to lambda divided by n I just
rearranged this up here right so our
probability of success is lambda times n
lambda times N and we're saying what's
the probability that we have K successes
and then what's the probability that we
have a failure well it's 1 minus the
probability of success and how many
failures we're going to have how many
moments will not have a car pass well we
have total of n moments and K of them
were successes so we'll have n minus K
failures let's see what we can do with
this so this is equal to let me rewrite
it all and I'll change colors the limit
is n approaches infinity let me write
out this binomial coefficient that's n
factorial over n minus K factorial times
K factorial normally I write these the
other way around but it's the same thing
times C lambda to the K I'm just using
my exponent properties over n to the K
and then this expression right here I
can actually separate out the X plus
this is the same thing as 1 minus lambda
over N to the N times 1 minus lambda
over N to the minus K right you have the
same base you could add the exponents
and you would get this up here and let
me simplify a little bit more
let me let me swap spots with these two
right there both you can kind of view
them both as being in the denominator so
you can change the order of division or
multiplication depending how you view it
so this is equal to the limit let me
switch colors the limit as n approaches
infinity I don't like that color of well
what was let's let actually let me just
rewrite what we did in the last video
what is this thing right here and we
showed it at the end of the last video n
factorial divided by n minus K factorial
it was n times n minus 1 times n minus 2
all the way to n minus k plus 1 right if
this was 7 over 7 minus 2 factorial we
would have 7 times 6 right and 6 is 1
more than 7 minus 2 so that's where we
got that and we did that in the last
video if you're getting confused and we
also said that there's going to be
exactly K terms here so if you counted
these as 1 2 3 all the way there's going
to be K terms here and so that we took
care of that we just rewrote that and I
said I would switch these two things
around so that's divided by divided by n
to the K n to the K times I'm just
switching these lambda to the K over K
factorial over K factorial and then what
do we have here we have well I can just
rewrite that this is continuing the same
line 1 minus lambda over N to the N
times 1 minus lambda over N to the minus
K now we can take the limit so what
happens when we take the load so just
you know if you take the limit this is
another property that just so you don't
get too overwhelmed another property of
limits if I take the limit as X
approaches anything a of f of X times G
of X that's equal to the limit as X
approaches a of f of X times the limit
as X approaches a of G of X right so we
could take each of these limits in the
product and then multiply them and then
what
all set so let's do that and I want to
leave this stuff up here so first of all
what's this limit let me write this out
and let me pick a good color yellow so
we have the limit the limit as n
approaches infinity so this thing up
here this n times n minus 1 times n
minus 2 all the way down to n minus k
plus 1 what's it going to look like it's
going to be a polynomial right we're
multiplying a bunch of well really we're
multiplying a bunch of binomials we're
doing it K times so the largest degree
term is going to be n to the K right
it's going to be n to the K a plus
something times n to the K minus 1 it's
going to be you know this big kind of
binomial this big polynomial Kait degree
polynomial and that's really all we need
to know for this derivation so it's
going to be n to the K plus bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla a bunch of other stuff
this thing when you multiply it out over
we have this n to the K right so we just
that's this part of it times the limit
as well actually we don't have to worry
this is a constant so we could actually
bring this out front so we don't even
have to write a limit so times lambda to
the K over K factorial right there's no
n here so this is a constant with
respect to n times the limit as n
approaches infinity of 1 minus lambda
over N to the N times 1 minus lambda
over N to the minus K all right I know
you can barely see look read this let's
see so first of all what's this limit
the limit as n approaches infinity of
some polynomial where it's n to the K
power plus blah blah blah blah where all
of these other terms have a lower degree
this is the highest degree term right
this is the highest degree term so you
have n to the K in the numerator and you
have n to the K in the denominator so
the highest degrees are the same the
coefficients are 1 so this limit is 1
another way you could do it you could
divide the numerator in the denominator
by n to the K and you would get you know
this would be 1 over this would just be
1 plus 1 over you know n plus 1 over
everything else would have a 1 over n in
it and this would just be a 1 and if you
take the limit as you approach infinity
all of these other terms would be zero
and you get left with one over one but
either way you have the same degree in
the top and the bottom and their
coefficients are the same so the limit
is n approaches infinity of this is one
which is a nice simplification so you
end up with 1 times lambda K over K
factorial now what's the limit as n
approaches infinity of this thing right
here 1 minus lambda over N to the N well
in the last video we show that it would
be I'll write it right here that the
limit as n approaches infinity of 1 plus
a over N to the N is equal to e to the a
right that's exactly what we have here
but instead of an a we have a minus
lambda right minus lambda so this is
going to be equal to e to the minus
lambda right we have a minus lambda
instead of an A and then finally what's
the limit as n approaches infinity let
me write it a little bit neater of one
this I'm just rewriting this term 1
minus lambda over N to the minus K power
what happens is n approaches infinity
well this this term right lambda is a
constant is this approaches infinity
this term is going to approach is 0 so
you have 1 to the minus K 1 to any power
is 1 so that term becomes 1 so we have
another one there so there you have it
we're we're done the probability the
probability that our random variable the
number of cars that pass in an hour is
equal to a particular number you know
it's equal to 7 cars passing an hour is
equal to the limit as n approaches
infinity of n choose K times times what
we said it was lambda over N to the to
the K successes times 1 minus lambda
over N to the N minus K failures and we
just show that this is equal to lambda
to the K power over K factorial times e
to the minus lambda and that's pretty
neat because when you just see it in
kind of a vacuum if you have no context
for it you wouldn't guess that this is
in any way related to the by
Gnomeo theorem I mean it's got an e in
there it's got a factorial but you know
a lot of things have factorials in life
so not clear that that would make it a
binomial theorem but this is just the
limit as you take smaller and smaller
smaller intervals and the probability of
success in each interval becomes smaller
but as you take the limit you end up
with E and if you think about it makes
sense because one of our derivations of
V actually came out of compound interest
and we kind of did something similar
there we took smaller and smaller
intervals of compounding and over each
interval we compounded by a much smaller
number and when you took the limit
you got a again and that's actually
where that whole formula up here came up
came from to begin with anyway just so
that you know how to use this thing so
let's say that I were to go out I'm the
traffic engineer and I figure out that
on average nine cars passed per hour
nine cars pass and I want to know the
probability I want to know the
probability that so this is my expected
value or and in a given hour on average
nine cars are passing so I want to
probably that that two cars pass in a
given hour exactly two cars pass it's
going to be equal to nine cars per hour
to the toothpowder
or four squared instead of the tooth
power divided by 2 factorial times e to
the minus 9 power so it's equal to 81
over 2 times e to the minus 9 power and
let's see maybe I should just get the
graphing calculator out there well I'll
let you do that exercise to figure out
what that is but I'll see you in the
next video